[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
28 ou 2021 montréal
la boxeuse mexicaine jeannette zacharias
zapata reçoit une série de coups à la
tête
quelques instants plus tard elle perd
connaissance
transporté d'urgence à l'hôpital elle ne
se réveillera jamais
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on voit équipée comment les caves à vin
castroneves ne savent pas tout en fera
par un coup trop ce combat ravive de
mauvais souvenirs pour éric martel
bahoeli qui a été boxeur pendant vingt
ans il y a quelques années son meilleur
ami dv de huit hommes a lui aussi reçu
un coup fatal
mais son de serre la main de finir
champions puis malheureusement ça est un
combat de trop qui a fait se fait mettre
au monde et puis étant de la cour morts
puis fnam est décédé par la suite pour
eric ces deux décès tragique aurait pu
être évité car les deux athlètes n'en
étaient pas à leur première commotion
cérébrale
[Musique]
à peine trois mois avant son ultime
combat
janet d'acadia zapata avait subi un
autre cas au fulgurant au mexique
selon le neuropsychologue des veys
lembergs spécialiste des commotions
cérébrales la boxeuse du 18 ans n'aurait
pas dû monter sur le ring à montréal
quand elle apprend qu'un athlète par
connaissance à la suite d'un coup à la
tête
un coût important est dans un état
critique
une des premières hypothèses qui nous
vient en tête c'est un syndrome second
impact
le syndrome du second impact se produit
lorsqu'un athlète subi une deuxième
commotion cérébrale
alors que la première n'est pas encore
guéri
il faudra attendre le rapport du coroner
pour connaître les véritables causes de
la mort de jeannette zacharias zapata
mais le docteur helberg crois que c'est
ce syndrome qui l'a tué
on se dit c'est pas le premier coup
qu'elle a eu dans un court laps de temps
est sûrement
u23 même plusieurs et là c'est le type
d'événement qui peut envoyer le cerveau
en vrille
pour comprendre le syndrome du second
impact il faut d'abord s'intéresser aux
conséquences d'une première commotion
cérébrale
lorsque le cerveau subi un impact cela
cause une série de bouleversements
d'abord des déchirures microscopique au
niveau des axones qui redit les neurones
le cerveau subie aussi un débalancement
chimiques qui draine énormément de son
énergie
cela cause une inflammation du cerveau
et affectent l'activité des neurones
le cerveau perd alors la capacité de
réguler la pression dans ces vaisseaux
sanguins
durant cette période de fragilité
si le cerveau encaissent un second
impact même mineur l'effet peut être
catastrophique
la pression augmente alors de façon
incontrôlée dans les vaisseaux sanguins
et le cerveau se met à enfler rapidement
[Musique]
et ça ça peut occasionner une
augmentation massive de la pression
intracrânienne et c'est ça qui peut
blesser le cerveau et qui peut mener
donc à la perte de connaissance
la convulsion l'épilepsie et dans
certains cas les chirurgiens doivent
intervenir rapidement pour pouvoir
libérer donc le cerveau de cette
pression là ce qu'ils vont faire ces
deux d'ouvrir en partie de la calotte
crânienne pour laisser un peu d'espacé
certains s'en remettre mais avec de
lourdes séquelles comme le footballeur
américain preston pleuvry tease victime
du syndrome du second impact en 2015 à
l'âge de 19 ans
dans d'autres cas
invention ne suffit pas et c'est la mort
c'est ce qui est arrivé à roanne
stringer une joueuse de rugby de 17 ans
qui a subi deux commotions cérébrales en
une semaine en 2013
et ce n'est pas par hasard si les
victimes du syndrome second impact sont
tous de jeunes adultes
[Musique]
en termes de facteurs de risque le
premier c'est l'ange on sait que les
personnes âgées de 2 10 12 ans jusqu'à
22 25 ans sont beaucoup plus à risque de
subir le nom de second impact on croit
parce que leur cerveau est en pleine
poussée de croissance
j'en ai déjà car hiace zapata avait un
autre facteur de risque celui d'être une
femme on croit que les hommes ont certes
un facteur de neuro protection cérébrale
qui seraient liées aux hormones comme
par exemple testé step un petit qui fait
en sorte que la femme par exemple les
plus fragiles à tout impact à la tête
haute ou de blessure il ya également des
facteurs au niveau musculo squelettiques
les muscles du cou des épaules chez les
hommes sont plus développées en général
et vont mieux protégé des impacts
alors comment éviter le syndrome du
second impact il faut d'abord que la
première commotion soit détectée puis
traitées adéquatement
le problème ce type de blessure passe
souvent inaperçu surtout en boxe et
parfois volontairement
d étude toute récente nous suggèrent que
plus d'un athlète sur deux ne rapportera
pas les symptômes qu'ils ressemblent
qu'il reconnaisse ressentir quand il
fait de la boxe un sport de combat nous
montrer qu'ils étaient solides et offre
bat mars à ce que puis capable d'en
prendre mais sinon tu veux pas parler de
soi faire comme si de rien n'était parce
que c'est comme si c'était un peu mal vu
et l'entourage des boxeurs ne fait pas
toujours le nécessaire pour s'assurer
que la commotion cérébrale soient bien
dirigées
après le combat le médecin bien que la
petite lampe de poche et regarde tes
yeux qui dit ok mon astuce pas trois
mois parce que c'est un banco mais y'a
rien qui dit qu'après trois mois même
s'ils me disent qu'ils étaient
réellement guéri
après son ko 2 mai 2021 j'allais à
kariat zapata a vu un médecin qui lui a
effectivement prescrit trois mois de
repos mais était ce suffisant
pas selon les professionnels de
l'institut des commotions cérébrales de
montréal
il ya quelques années on parlait de
rester dans une chambre noire au repos
complet en attendant que les symptômes
se résorbe mais non on voit qu'en
faisant ça ça peut diminuer le seuil de
tolérance où les capacités de l'individu
donc maintenant on parle d'une
réintégration progressive aux activités
tant au niveau physique que canine afin
de permettre une réadaptation plus
efficace
[Musique]
leur approche est multidisciplinaire
les athlètes sont d'abord évalués sur
plusieurs plans la thérapeute bien qu'à
brigitte rock notent leurs symptômes
physiques par exemple les douleurs et
les étourdissements leurs symptômes
cognitifs tels que les problèmes de
mémoire et de concentration
leurs symptômes affectif comme
l'irritabilité et l'anxiété et
finalement leurs troubles du sommeil
à partir de cette évaluation les
athlètes sont prises en charge par une
équipe de professionnels de la santé
tels que des médecins des
physiothérapeutes et des
neuropsychologues
avant de retourner au jeu l'athlète subi
différents tests pour vérifier ses
capacités physiques et cognitives
parfois la personne peut avoir aucun
symptôme même deux qui vont s'intégrer
dans un milieu sportif où ils doivent
avant des réflexes des temps de réaction
rapide changement de direction est en
mesure de lire le jeu avoir une bonne
lecture de leur environnement sportif
c'est là on fait qu'on veut s'assurer
que c'est que leur capacité fond de
retour aux fonctions unis savent
le docteur et lembergs collabore avec
l'institut des commotions cérébrales
pour développer des outils encore plus
pointue
dans ce test le patient est d'exposer à
des images stressante pendant que le
chercheur examine sa réaction
on sait que les coups à la tête à
répétition peuvent affecter la région
frontale du cerveau qui est impliqué
dans la gestion du stress la régulation
des émotions donc en utilisant le
contrôle et l'observation des mouvements
oculaires qui combinait avec la
présentation d'image on est capable
d'aller voir comment le cerveau arriva à
gérer des situations de stress et sa
peur l'ultime à devenir un outil pour
détecter les signes avant-coureurs de
troubles de régulation des émotions
[Musique]
le chercheur vérifie aussi les facultés
cognitives de l'athlète pendant qu'il
est en action
pourquoi la tête retourne au jeu des
petits dont on lui fait faire des tests
cognitifs des tests de mémoire
d'attention et eux ils doivent réussir
ces épreuves là pour retourner au jeu
mais quand ils font si tesla les
athlètes sont au repos des études
récentes dans laboratoire nous démontre
que quand on combine un effort physique
important comme par exemple marcher
rapidement ou courir sur un tapis de
course en même temps qu'on fait une
tâche cognitive complexe l'un des
symptômes qui ressorte qui ne ressortent
pas normalement quand l'athlète fait la
même tâche mais à 6 ou au repos
en ce moment avant de prendre part à un
match de boxe les athlètes doivent
passer un scanner du cerveau
jeannette zacharias zapata s'étaient
soumises à cet examen et aucune anomalie
n'avait été détecté mais selon le
docteur hélène bergues
cette technique d'imagerie n'est tout
simplement pas adéquat le scan cérébral
typés comme la résonance magnétique par
exemple ne permet pas en fait de voir
d'imagés les conséquences des commotions
cérébrales dans le cerveau les
commotions cérébrales qui vont affecter
plus tôt les fibres ou les axxon et puis
qui vont causer un bouleversement
chimiques
c'est pourquoi dans son laboratoire il a
développé une technique d'imagerie plus
précise à l'aide d'électrodes cette
halle au gras mais de haute densité donc
plus de 128 électrodes sur la surface la
boîte crânienne on est capable de
mesurer des changements neuro électrique
des changements subtils en termes de
micro vote qui peuvent permettre de
détecter donc des déficits
associé aux commotions cérébrales qu'on
ne voit pas nécessairement avec
l'imagerie traditionnelle
c'est en s'assurant que la commotion
cérébrale est totalement guéri que l'on
pourra éviter le syndrome du second
impact
malheureusement même si la science
permet de bien diagnostiquer et traiter
les commotions cérébrales
ces mesures sont trop rarement appliquée
la boxe un sport beau sport +
chocolat dans ces milieux le pli jeu là
j'adore ça mais je pense qu'aussi offert
une conscientisation du que des gens
prennent plus conscience comment mais il
ya des vies humaines aussi en arrière
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]